[Musique]
tu sais Mia un dicton qui dit que
lorsqu'un démineur meurt son âme a pas
le temps de quitter son corps
trop rapidement
[Musique]
la route est bloquée les Alibaba ont
pris le village
désordre était de pas bouger
et les gens meurent autour de toi
unité en position
le groupe
il rentre bientôt à la maison
[Musique]
la mort est toujours proche
cette seconde
France Inter m house of the dragon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est toi que j'aime tu me souviens
reconnaissez-vous avoir 47
j'ai envie de vivre avec toi je l'ai
fait je l'ai vu l'enfoncer je l'ai vu là
détruire petit à petit
[Musique]
c'est quand même un peu coincé du cul
à chaque fois
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment besoin de votre aide
est-ce que vous avez perdu des choses
pendant cette relation aussi des amis
mon boulot mon appartement et mon fils
aussi j'ai perdu mon fils qu'est-ce que
je sais faire
le propre d'un pervers en fait c'est de
pousser jusqu'au suicide j'ai
l'impression d'être face à une victime
pas
[Musique]
à la folie
ce programme sera disponible en audio
description
sois patiente avec moi c'est une
nouvelle chanson
[Musique]
ce qui a tué Curtis Cooper et sa fiancée
elle a Paramé Toxie en fait amine
saviez-vous des suspicions qui se
droguaient à nouveau des signes
je sais Curtis avait décroché je vais
pas parler depuis des mois
vous ne croyez pas qu'il puisse y avoir
une minuscule possible
pour faire croire à une overdose
je veux juste réussir à comprendre
ce sera ma dernière pièce adieu 12
Hamlets vous connaissez cet homme et ce
type est l'un des plus grands
importateurs de PMA de la ville est-ce
que je peux vous aider
je suis venu voir si tu pouvais m'aider
on l'appelle le jardinier parce que il a
égorgé un mec avec des outils de
jardinage
c'est les trois gars qui cherchent de la
PMA dans la ville
vous savez Curtis va devenir une énorme
star
c'est trois [ __ ] doivent payer
je sais ce que tu as fait
des toasts
il y a de nouveaux éléments qui selon
nous pour être liés à la mort de votre
fils c'était tellement bizarre
j'ai eu cette impression que Ronin est
vraiment dans le coup
ce mec me fait trop flipper
vous vous êtes trompé de personne
tu connais cette très bien Olivia
je veux vraiment pas qui est d'animosité
entre nous
je pense qu'on doit être plus discrète
cette fois je vais vous tirer dessus
[Musique]
justice sera rendue